depuis un an la pandémie chamboule la
vie des canadiens et une grande
lassitude s'est installée chez les lolo
on a pas de fatalité rendu à point que
c'est fatigant là pour connaître l'état
d'esprit des canadiens trois mille
personnes ont été sondés par la firme
ipsos entre le 12 et le 17 février veut
bout à l'autre du pays malgré le
déploiement du vaccin 34 % des
répondants se disent plus pessimistes
qu'à l'automne dernier nouveau
confinement nouveaux variants il ya eu
quand même beaucoup de mauvaises
nouvelles à la tripe 2021 est ce qu'on
voit ce que les gens ne sont pas plus
optimistes en ce moment qu'il ne l'était
à l'automne
voyez un peu la lumière à la fin du
tunnel mais là depuis octobre si la
pandémie a eu d'importantes
répercussions sur la vie des canadiens
71 % affirment que leur vie sociale
s'est détériorée 46% disent que c'est le
cas pour leur santé mentale et 35% pour
leurs finances personnelles faire faire
un haka ce travail pour les jeunes de 18
à 34 ans sont touchés plus durement
certains égards 59% d'entre eux disent
que leur santé mentale s'est détériorée
et 43% subi des répercussions sur leurs
finances personnelles
klépierre la performance du gouvernement
fédéral dans le dossier de la
vaccination ne semble pas impressionner
les canadiens
un répondant sur deux se dit insatisfait
de la distribution des vaccins ou d'un
gouvernement et un avertissement alors
on sait que la vaccination est très très
importante pour un retour à la normale
et là on voit que les canadiens se poser
question les deux tiers des canadiens
appuient isolement de trois jours à
l'hôtel pour les voyageurs mais la
moitié des répondants pensent que cette
mesure est arrivé trop tard
la semaine de relâche qui s'amorce dans
certaines régions suscite de grandes
inquiétudes
sept canadiens sur dix pensent qu'elle
mènera un nouveau confinement
ces classes voire plus un rassemblement
puisque tout le monde est en congé trois
canadiens sur quatre anticipe
déconfinement à répétition au cours de
la prochaine année
il serait prêt à faire ce sacrifice dans
une proportion presque identique
76% des répondants appuierait un nouveau
confinement pour ralentir la propagation
des variables il faut faire il faut
faire ses preuves mais sans pop unis de
faire un compliment
oui j'irai en faveur c'est sous ce n'est
pas facile mais parce qu'il faut prendre
des décisions saint-paul celui de vos
plans de chance ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle pour le gouvernement s'il va
demander des efforts supplémentaires à
la population la population vaut sans
doute accepté de les faire même si c'est
pas douter qu'un c'est quand même
rassurant de voir que la population à
cette solidarité et est prête à faire ce
qu'il faut faire pour affronter la
pandémie lagarde majorité des canadiens
sont résignés à respecter les mesures
sanitaires pour combattre la pandémie du
moins pour le moment
plus de la moitié des répondants pensent
qu'il faudra attendre à l'an prochain ou
même plus tard pour retrouver une vie à
peu près normale ici olivier bachand
radio canada montréal